why do you love making mistakes
i think mistakes make amazing stories
if i'm ever
in a horrible place or i made a huge
mistake
i'll instantly
just grasp for some comedy of the moment
because
you might as well use it you know
i think i think a lot of uh drama too
comes from laughing about mistakes
you know i think i think good log lines
come from
laughing about mistakes my favorite like
log lines from movies are ones where you
have the
the air blow through your nose you know
you read it you go
you know
so i love mistakes i try to embrace them
well i think we have a quote here um
and sorry to quote you i know it's kind
of it's kind of weird but okay here here
we go so we have a quote here i learned
that when i throw myself into the fire
and if i don't feel the heat i've failed
comfort is the death of progress that's
pretty brilliant wow i like that
i sound like a dictator
no well okay but i mean i i get what
you're talking about because if you if
you're just comfortable all the time
you're not growing you're not doing
anything you're kind of staying stagnant
yeah um can you give us examples of how
you've made yourself either purposely
uncomfortable or
life has thrown you into those
circumstances yeah yeah um
i feel like uh
this probably came from moving around in
my life a lot like moving to different
countries and locations and schools all
the time it started as schools then it
was cities and countries um and then
careers uh
you know at one point i wanted to be
approached snowboarder you know and then
i moved to the desert with my mom and i
was like well so much for that but um
uh yeah i think
moving around a lot uh teaches you
to reinvent yourself teaches you
makes you really look at yourself you
know you get this opportunity to
um
redefine every
part of you really
and i think that has taught me
that that can be a very powerful thing
with uh art too you know
i think
like i mentioned playing music a little
bit um
that's been a good
outlet for me to come back to the movies
i make
and really look at them in a different
way
and that goes with acting it goes with
writing it goes to producing it goes
with directing editing and that's why i
love doing all those things because they
all inform each other and when you're
struggling with one
you can always focus on another one that
can inform you know what you were
struggling with
so
yeah if there's any opportunity to throw
yourself in the fire i mean you can't
get burnt so you got to be careful and
you got to have people around you tell
you to chill out or or just have a great
team of people you can collaborate with
but i think it's a healthy thing
for an artist
how many times were you the new kid in
class
oh man
it'd be interesting to count
all right one two three
four five six seven uh to man i was
probably the new kid in class like seven
times before i like graduated uh high
school and by class i mean like school
or maybe more yeah i think like nine
maybe actually now that i think of it um
but uh yeah i always thought there was
like a problem with me like when i was
going to high school specifically but i
mean even from elementary school i
remember telling my mom i was like i
think i'm dyslexic i think i'm dyslexic
uh
i guess there's like tests for it or the
teachers would like comment on what they
think about it they just send me like a
counselor like no you're not um there's
nothing wrong with you and i was like
dang it like there's nothing wrong with
me and then i just realized i don't like
school and school had no uh no outlet
for me to learn what i i love doing uh
the only thing i ever found that had
information that i really
grasped onto and took and used in my
real life is youtube like
when i was like 11 or something i i
think youtube just became a thing back
then and uh
and that's how i learned how to edit and
and that i started watching little
scenes of movies like bootleg uploaded
to youtube and uh i'd watch that and uh
that was
where i learned everything i've even
seen you guys videos by the way i didn't
even mention this but i i watched film a
few film courage videos uh in
pre-production uh of my dead dad oh wow
and uh that
that's amazing to me that's amazing that
you can be a kid in the middle east you
know and no not a single filmmaker
and yet know all the filmmakers
and take something from that
wow very cool well thank you that's
that's pretty cool yeah i was wondering
though if that actually helps you that
uncomfortable you know it's always
uncomfortable going to a new school or
having to go to you know high school and
you're the freshman and
you don't know anyone but if you've done
that
let's say more than five times i wonder
if that's actually helped you with
auditions because how uncomfortable is
it to go into a room with a bunch of
other people reading sides and they're
all up for the same part and yeah oh
yeah hey how's it going you know and but
everybody's there for you know they're
your competition
um and then but you've been through that
i just thought that was interesting
maybe it's helpful yeah yeah now that is
interesting i i definitely think uh
moving schools has helped me
in many facets of my life i i like to
think
semi-cognizant and human communication i
said that like a robot so maybe not but
um moving schools is definitely kind of
like auditioning for different groups of
people and and even if you've never
moved into school uh you know
like moved
moved into high school from middle
school like that's a different group of
people instantly you know and i think i
think the greatest thing i ever learned
in school was just how to communicate
and watch people um and i think by
moving so many times that definitely
helps with that
um
absolutely and and maybe there's like a
an aspect of moving too where especially
moving different countries you're kind
of the weird kid already just by like
default um
you know uh
i mean it's funny but like moving to
peru for example i'm peruvian but i
don't look peruvian so
being the white kid there is
is
technically the minority if you can say
that you know
in peru so it instantly gave me a
different perspective that i would have
never gotten just living in seattle um
and i think because of that i was okay
with being a little
weird or myself really
um and the older i get and the more i do
this movie making stuff is that i
realize that's the only thing you really
have to offer like your weirdness your
you you know so even now
you know i i've had friends of friends
or
friends of girls i was dating you know
be like
you're weird dude
and i used to be like um and now i'm
kind of like nice that's good okay i'm
being myself like i like that um
and maybe i'm leaning into it too much
now but it's
i just feel like you're getting so many
more interesting conversations and and
come up with movie ideas and and
and you don't start molding yourself uh
you know this
thing
that you're not and then when you make
movies
then you're making movies that aren't
you and that's not authentic and
everyone can pick up on that so
right yeah
no i love that all right but yeah
what about the horrible word of um sell
out
what what does that conjure up because i
know a lot of people that are very
authentic and and revel sort of relish
in their weirdness for lack of a better
term i think they're afraid of the word
sellout
because then that means
being sort of this corporate
thing but sometimes you have to be a
sellout i think yeah
yeah
i um
i think being a sellout is doing
something
i think being a seller i was getting is
getting behind something that you don't
believe in like on a on a deeper level
you know what i mean i mean like
i've done plenty of jobs that i
am like you know about um
but
at the time
it was right for me to do because i
needed to learn certain things
and it was just another challenge really
so
i think you get
you can
be more fortunate the longer you stick
around in this business and you can
choose the
skirt around
sell out feeling things a little bit
more
but
um
i don't really it's funny i haven't
heard that word in forever because like
i think i'm dating myself
no and it's also just because like
i think i'm working with uh
with more pros these days you know what
i mean who who kind of understand like
you know hey like this is not a genre or
a thing that i'm like naturally drawn to
but
you know what i could really make it
better because i see it this way you
know and and it's a creative challenge
almost um
and also i have a family and kids
and a mortgage
um
but uh
but yeah once you start
i think once you start bringing that
energy back into your own stuff that is
supposed to be the passion project kind
of uh
movies or whatever it may be that's
where you're starting to get into
trouble like i've even had conversations
or brainstorming sessions with
collaborators of mine who we've come up
with an idea and we're like oh that's
cool and oh that would work really well
right now because of this or like
people would like that you know and then
we're like hold on hold on you know like
do we like that
no
never mind you know um
so it really depends on the context i
feel like the word sellout to me
did that come up at all um with your
first feature film my dad dad where
there were something where you're like
you know what that would have been
that'd be too corporate or whatever i am
yeah oh you did okay no absolutely
absolutely and uh making your first
feature is like can be hell
and it's like a miracle that like you
get through it um
so you do sometimes
have to
um
compromise on small things and and you
really have to put your foot down at
other times and be like this is
where it stops you know like we're
maintaining this vision you know like we
want to shoot with two cameras like
that's what we're gonna do or
or um we're not gonna make this uh
um
we're not gonna cater to like a tv
network to to
change the title or whatever like people
either hated the title or love the title
and maybe talk to me in eight months
when the movies are public you'll be
like it wasn't called my dead dog
but
uh but i will say that you know those
are one of those things i was really
insistent at least you know keeping it
through through the festival run of
being like no this is like the title
like it's i i
some people hate it some people love it
everyone definitely double takes at it
um
and it's representative of the movie you
know um
of course we wanted to shoot on film
originally you know like that is a uh
okay that's um i guess a compromise we
made we shot on two digital cameras uh
but
uh
but we didn't compromise on our color
to make it look like film
so it's the ebb and flow for sure
if i saw that title on netflix in in
suggested i would definitely click on it
just to see what the log line was no so
it does work yeah um i hope so for me at
least but yeah so people thought maybe
it was too off-putting the title yeah
there was um
there was times where people were like
well so it's such a personal title to
where depending on how you feel about
the world or your parents you're gonna
get a different reaction because my dead
dad some people have been like oh my god
that's so dark or you know
whatever uh
and other people have been like
so it's like a comedy or yeah yeah
yeah and i kind of love it because it
describes our movie pretty well where
it's got some heavy moments but it's
also got some moments where you're like
what you know like two guys hanging out
talking about you know like
uh
you just got to watch the movie
yeah right
but
uh funny moments
yeah guys being guys yes guys being guys
yeah
yeah yeah and that's another one too uh
there was a lot of a lot of pages in the
script where
some of it just came from real life
conversations you know um just
conversations that you would have alone
with you know your close friends
um and we got notes on certain stuff and
we just kept them you know the great
thing about like shooting
is that there's always the editing of it
and you get to rewrite everything anyway
so when anyone ever gives you such like
a do or die script note i'm just like
no like if you believe in it just keep
it in like you you can always decide
later that's the beauty
and the difference between like doing
something live and shooting and cutting
it and it's a whole process so
stay true to your script all right
and don't worry women are just as bad
[Laughter]
pretend
yes
i've eavesdropped yes there you go
ex-girlfriend conversation